Transcription: Hasmik Sahakyan
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Est-ce que vous avez
des enfants de six ans ?
Ou est-ce que vous avez des souvenirs
de lorsque vous aviez six ans ?
Laissez-moi vous raconter une histoire.
Il était une fois, un petit garçon
qui se cachait dans une caverne,
parce que le village où il habitait
avait été brûlé par de méchants dragons.
Sa maman était morte dans l'incendie
et son papa avait disparu.
Dans sa grotte, il était entouré
de dragons et d'ossements humains.
Il ne lui restait que la couverture
laissée par son papa.
Un jour, il entend une étoile
qui l'appelle.
Et qui lui demande de la suivre.
Alors,
il quitte sa grotte,
il laisse sa couverture,
et il suit l'étoile.
Sur la route, il rencontre un écureuil,
un blaireau
et tous trois suivent l'étoile.
Quand l'étoile va doucement,
ils marchent doucement
et quand elle va vite, ils courent.
Chemin faisant, ils rencontrent aussi
le frère de son papa,
qui est caché derrière une maison,
et qui, lui aussi,
va les aider dans leur quête.
Quelques dragons de la grotte
les suivent, mais à distance.
Ils marchent tous ensemble et un jour
ils arrivent dans un paysage magique.
C'est magnifique.
Tout brille !
Dans ce paysage, il ya un grand arbre
au sommet duquel est caché un trésor.
L'enfant sait qu'il va devoir
attraper ce trésor.
La tâche est rude.
Le trésor est très haut.
Bien sûr, il pourrait utiliser l'écureuil,
qui peut grimper facilement aux arbres,
mais ce n'est pas ça l'idée.
Ce serait tricher.
C'est lui, qui doit attraper le trésor.
Il y a un autre obstacle.
Un arbre très grand à côté,
une sorte de gardien
qui veille sur le trésor․
Il sait que l'étoile va l'aider,
mais il ne sait pas encore comment.
Et puis, tout à coup, il voit
de cet arbre gardien une branche
qui monte et monte dangereusement
vers le soleil et tout brûle.
Puis, la neige arrive
et se met à tout nettoyer.
C'est la fête !
Le petit garçon a retrouvé le trésor.
Il n'a pas encore retrouvé son papa,
mais il sait maintenant
qu'il va réussir sa quête.
Avant de repartir, ils regardent
tous ensemble le paysage désolé,
mais une goutte verte descend d'un arbre,
et l'enfant sait que tout va repousser.
Avant de repartir également,
il va voir l'un des dragons et lui dit :
« Tu ne veux pas nous aider et nous suivre
dans notre quête, marcher avec nous ? »
Et le dragon accepte.
Ils repartent tous ensemble,
guidés par l'étoile,
qui est de plus en plus belle
et qui les mène
jusqu'au papa du petit garçon.
À la fin, le roi des dragons lui-même,
regarde les retrouvailles
de ce petit garçon, de son papa
et de son oncle.
Alors, l'histoire,
que je viens de vous raconter,
c'est celle de Teddy,
un petit garçon de six ans.
Teddy a travaillé avec moi
pendant 12 semaines,
à raison d'une séance
d'une heure par semaine.
Il a simplement dessiné en écoutant
une musique au fort pouvoir évocateur.
Et il a raconté ce qu'il dessinait.
Vous allez voir ses dessins.
J'ai oublié de mettre
ma diapositive avant.
(Rires)
Vous allez voir ses dessins.
C'est le parcours d'un héros.
C'est étonnant de voir
la continuité de son histoire,
parce que Teddy n'a revu ni ses dessins,
ni son histoire d'une séance à l'autre.
Et ce durant trois mois.
On a tous les ingrédients du conte.
On a d'abord l'épreuve initiale
avec l'incendie qui brûle tout.
Puis...
(En pensant)
L'enfant qui se retrouve seul
dans sa grotte sans père, ni mère.
Ensuite, viennent les alliés,
qui lui donnent la force
de s'engager dans sa quête.
L'allié principal c'est l'étoile
qui va le suivre
tout au long de son parcours
et qui va le mener au centre de lui-même.
L'allié - l'étoile, c'est son guide
intérieur, c'est sa part lumineuse.
C'est la partie, vous avez vu
dans son histoire,
comme il veille à se mettre à l'écoute.
J'adore ces phrases des enfants,
c'est quand l'étoile marche doucement.
Il se met à l'écoute de la partie
de lui même, celle qui sait.
Mais, il y a aussi des adversaires -
les dragons.
Vous avez observé qu'il n'en a pas peur,
malgré leur aspect destructeur.
Au contraire, il veille à les intégrer
au fil de son histoire.
Et, ce faisant, les dragons
deviennent des alliés,
qui l'aident également dans sa quête.
Là aussi une autre formule, que j'adore.
En travaillant avec son dragon,
il me regarde et me dit :
« Les dragons c'est un peu
un truc de légende. »
Il redessine.
Il lève la tête :
« Mais les légendes
c'est un peu vrai aussi. »
Après les dragons, moment important
dans l'histoire c'est l'ultime épreuve,
qui va permettre au héros
de se qualifier comme tel.
Regardez ce dessin numéro sept.
Ce dessin nous fait penser à l'histoire
de Jason et la conquête de la Toison d'or.
La Toison d'or était elle aussi
au sommet d'un grand arbre
et elle était gardée par un dragon.
Mais Jason n'a pas tué le dragon
en un combat héroïque.
Il l'endort grâce à un philtre
préparé par Médée.
Oui, il obtient la Toison d'or,
mais malhonnêtement, par la ruse.
Or Teddy a bien précisé,
qu'il ne voulait pas que son héros
utilise l'écureuil.
C'est lui qui doit atteindre le trésor,
gage de la réussite de sa quête.
L'enfant, se faisant, aborde aussi
les éléments difficiles de son ombre.
Il n'a pas peur d'exprimer ses conflits,
ces tensions, sa de volonté puissance,
jusqu'au moment où
la neige vient tout nettoyer.
Ce faisant, dans ce parcours de héros,
eh bien, Teddy réussit sa quête,
et les trois figures masculines
sont réunis : le papa, l'oncle, l'enfant.
Je suis sûr que vous vous demandez :
« Pourquoi il n'y a que de figures
masculines dans ce conte ? »
Et vous vous dites :
« Oh là là, on a tué sa maman. »
On est sur un plan symbolique.
L'enfant avait besoin de se reconnecter
avec ce principe masculin,
qui lui manque tant dans sa croissance.
En effet, les parents de Teddy
ont divorcé il y a deux ans.
Et, le système de garde fait
qu'il voit très peu son papa.
Et donc, il n'arrivait pas à exprimer
que son papa lui manquait.
C'est donc une étape importante pour lui,
d'avoir réussi à poser ce cheminement
de réclamer son papa
pour sa croissance psychique.
Autre point important pour Teddy,
c'est qu'il, il...
Il avance,
et donc, il nous montre le parcours,
l'importance d'aider les enfants
à découvrir leur monde intérieur.
Ça n'est pas quelque chose d'inutile,
c'est quelque chose d'important,
parce que l'univers intérieur
recèle des qualités,
des ressources cachées des trésors,
qu'il faut aider à révéler
pour affronter le réel.
Le dessin est un média magique
pour aborder les conflits.
Ainsi, les parents, autour des dessins,
ont pu parler
et trouver des solutions et des stratégies
pour aider Teddy dans sa croissance.
Ainsi, si Teddy doit passer
par une phase d'apprentissage,
parce que la maman a consulté,
en plus de ses problèmes,
donc son papa a divorcé,
il était colérique et inquiet,
il avait du mal
à se connecter aux autres.
Et surtout, il répétait en boucle
à chaque situation de stress :
« On m'en demande trop,
c'est trop difficile. »
Donc, la maman cherchait
des solutions pour apaiser son enfant.
Et donc, ça nous ramène à cette nécessité
de la façon dont nous nous occupons
de nos enfants et de l'importance,
en fait, en tant qu'adulte,
d'aider les enfants à donner
un sens à leur vie.
Pour Teddy, ayant fait
ce parcours et s'étant libéré,
puisque à la fin
il allait vers les autres,
il s'est fait des copains,
il pleurait moins,
il avait voulu participer
à un sport collectif.
Donc, il ne sera pas identifié
à un symptôme,
même s'il doit passer
par une phase de rééducation.
Le symptôme ne sera pas un dragon
destructeur qui menace tout son équilibre.
Ce sera simplement un élément,
un point faible sur lequel
on pourra trouver des solutions.
Pour grandir, se construire,
l'enfant a besoin de paix.
L'enfant est-il en paix
lorsque les enseignants et les parents
cherchent à déceler, dès leur plus
jeune âge, d'éventuelles faiblesses,
sans quoi, dit-on, leur parcours scolaire
et leur parcours de vie
sera forcément handicapé ?
L'enfant est-il en paix
quand la famille et l'école
deviennent un lieu de stress ?
Moi, je trouve, qu'ils ont bien raison
ces petit garçons, ces petites filles,
de se révolter, de se rebeller.
Imaginez la tension oppressante
lorsque l'enfant est vécu comme
un problème à la maison, à l'école.
Nous avons une responsabilité en tant
qu'adulte : les parents, les éducateurs :
celle d'aider nos enfants à grandir.
Si nous regardons nos enfants
comme un problème,
ils vont s'identifier à ce problème
et se vivront comme un problème.
Si au contraire,
on les regarde comme un être
en formation, avec un potentiel à révéler
et sur la confiance
en leurs ressources intérieures,
ils auront confiance en eux,
avec l'envie de grandir, de se construire,
de s'ouvrir au monde qui les entoure.
Alors,
avec Noël qui approche,
si riche en symboles,
je vous propose de vous questionnez
sur le sens que vous donnez à vos vies.
Je vous propose de réfléchir
et de créer un espace de paix
pour donner à vos enfants
non pas l'envie d'avoir,
mais celle d'être.
Je vous souhaite à tous en famille
de parler de l'esprit de Noël,
de partager et de dessiner
toutes les raisons d'émerveillement
de vos existences,
car, comme l'a dit Teddy :
« C'est un peu des légendes tout ça,
mais c'est un peu vrai aussi. »
(Applaudissements)